[Music]
I'm sure you and Jericho will form an
instant bond
I can't wait to meet him
[Music]
servant is basically two stories one is
this family that had this tragedy with
the death of their child it's called a
reborn doll
we lost Jericho when he was
13 weeks
each of the family members are dealing
with the grief in different ways
all three of them don't want to have the
conversation of what happened on that
day
and then the second story line is this
mysterious young woman who's a part of a
cult and who is Leanne has Leanne
brought their child Back to Life season
one Leanne is kind of a child and then
sometimes she's strong and a leader and
sometimes she's cowering and she hates
feeling like this this is the way she's
felt her whole life scared and
victimized
Leah
is there something you'd like to say to
your uncle
in season two we get to learn a little
bit about Leanne's history with the
church and a lot of Leanne's behavior is
tied to that
she's becoming very powerful and using
her anger to take control and saying you
know I'm no longer going to be the
victim I'm tired of everyone telling me
what's wrong with me
maybe there's nothing wrong
maybe this is who I am
at the end of season two you have a
Leanne that's Unapologetic
[Music]
and say I'm no longer going to listen to
rules I'm gonna do what I want to do
like some rest
at the top of season three you really
get a sense that the family is doing
well but hanging over all of this is the
inevitable break from the church
can you leave this cult there's a fear
that's growing in her which she hates
and so she learns to embrace her power
[Music]
and there's a defiant part of her all I
care about is this family she's tired of
being treated like a girl that doesn't
know anything and the power of the house
shifts to her saying you know what I've
brought your child back you guys need to
be grateful
I am frightened about what she might do
that power struggle starts to become
bigger and bigger
it will get kind of scary when she's
pushed too far I'll kill you do you
understand me I will kill you
[Music]
when we pick it up in season four the
two storylines have escalated
the domestic hostage situation that's
there with this family and then the
mythology of who is Leanne and what does
she represent
I heard people when I get angry
curious part is is that I'm starting to
like the way that it feels
[Music]
Leanne is almost an all-powerful being
and this family is terrified of her
trying very hard not to get angry
all ambiguity is gone and she is fully
in charge and ultimately season four
will be this biblical War that's
escalating on Spruce Street and in this
Brownstone
foreign
catastrophic
the whole world is going to change and
there's nothing that can stop this girl
you can feel the momentum moving to its
conclusion and I want the audience to go
oh we're at the end
what am I
you're evil
[Music]
foreign